light it's the fastest thing in the
universe but we can still measure its
speed if we slow down the animation we
can analyze lights motion using a
spacetime diagram which takes a flipbook
of animation panels and turns them on
their side in this lesson we'll add the
single experimental fact that whenever
anyone measures just how fast light
moves they get the same answer
299,792,458 meters every second which
means that when we draw a light on our
space-time diagram its world line always
has to appear at the same angle but we
saw previously that speeds or
equivalently worldline angles change
when we look at things from other
people's perspective to explore this
contradiction let's see what happens if
I start moving while I stand still and
shine the laser at tom first we'll need
to construct the space-time diagram yes
that means taking all of the different
panels showing different moments in time
and stacking them up from the side we
see the world line of the laser light at
its correct
fixed angle just as before so far so
good but that space-time diagram
represents Andrews perspective what does
it look like to me in the last lesson we
showed how to get Tom's perspective
moving all the panel's along a bit until
his world line is completely vertical
but look carefully at the light world
line the rearrangement of the panel's
means it's now tilted over too far I'd
measure light traveling faster than
hundred would but every experiment we've
ever done we've tried very hard says
that every one measures light to have a
fixed speed select R again in the 1900s
a clever chap named Albert Einstein
worked out how to see things properly
from Tom's point of view while still
getting the speed of light right first
we need to glue together the separate
panels into one solid block this gives
us our space time turning space and time
into one smooth continuous material and
now here is the trick what you do is
stretch your
knock of space-time along the light
world line then squash it by the same
amount but at right angles to the light
world line and abracadabra
Tom's world line has gone vertical so
this does represent the world from his
point of view but most importantly the
light world line has never changed its
angle and so light will be measured by
Tom going at the correct speed this
superb trick is known as a Lorentz
transformation yeah but more than a
trick slice up the space-time into new
panels and you have the physically
correct animation
I'm stationary in the car everything
else is coming past me at the speed of
light works out to be that same fixed
value that we know everyone meshes on
the other hand something strange has
happened the fence posts aren't spaced
two meter apart anymore and my mum will
be worried that I look a bit thin
but that's not fair why don't I get to
look thin
I thought physics were supposed to be
the same for everyone yes no it is and
you do all that stretching and squashing
of space-time is just muddled together
what we used to think of separately as
space and time this particular squashing
effect is known as Lorentz contraction
okay but I still don't look fit no yes
you do now that we know better about
space-time we should redraw what the
scene looked like to me to you
I appear Lorentz contracted oh but to
you I appear Lorentz contracted yes Oh
Lise it's fair and speaking of fairness
just as space gets muddled with time
time also gets muddled with space in an
effect known as time dilation mo at
everyday speeds such as Tom's car
reaches actually all the effects are
much much smaller than we've Illustrated
them oh yes careful experiments for
instance watching the behavior of tiny
particles whizzing around the Large
Hadron Collider confirmed the effects
are real and now that space-time is an
experimentally confirmed part of reality
we can get a bit more ambitious what if
we were to start playing with the
material of space-time itself we'll find
out all about that in the next animation